it's been a desperate struggle Alois
colored had nearly lost all hope for
years dozens of crows have called his
organic farm home leaving him no choice
but to sit back and watch as they
destroyed his salad crops nets
noisemakers balloons
nothing really helped last year alone
the loss of revenue amounted to forty
five thousand euros the celestials
1981 sequence in 2015 was really
critical
I feel quite helpless when you've had to
write off an entire harvest you just
don't know what to do anymore Collard is
fed up he's asked local authorities for
permission to shoot the crows after all
his is not the only farm being plagued
by the birds Daniel gamba is known as
the best Crow hunter in Switzerland and
has been tasks with the coal his mobile
plastic dummies attract the real birds
like magnets of dawn it's astonishing
that this simple method manages to trick
notoriously cunning crows as soon as
they approach their fate is sealed galva
shows no mercy and he's satisfied with
the result
[Music]
rotten fume Prosecco
we've got 34 crows this morning and
under the conditions that's a good yield
district animal rights activist catkin
Hockley believes the call is entirely
useless she says it won't control the
crow population
crows belong to the most intelligent
bird species so they're often portrayed
as black evil birds but actually they
have many abilities and are very
intelligent possibly too intelligent for
the liking of some humans but today
crows have been multiplying in this
region even if Daniel cava services are
more in demand than ever
unfortunately crow me does not make for
a delicious dish so will he be having
crows up tonight
definitely definitely not no no I eat
conventional foods conventional
certainly won't be serving up crow soup
local authorities will take stock at the
end of the year if crop damages have
declined the crows will be spared and
next year but at the moment it doesn't
look they will be that lucky